how are you boys going are you ovulating
you right
Australia is home to many exotic
creatures the platypus
the echidna the Cole the Koala but none
quite as unique as the Kidman the kidron
inhabits sorry the Kidman's habits
include oscar-winning Keith Urban Taming
deliciously down-to-earth deburring and
all-round spreading of life-affirming
joy and general gorgeousness her natural
habitat is the stage where she brilliant
Lee portrayed heroines like the
scientist rosalind Franklin or
illuminating the big screen with her
passionate nuanced and poignant
portrayals of women of substance
her most recent Oscar nomination is for
Lyon a bittersweet biopic in which he
gives a performance so heart-wrenching
it created a waterproof mascara shortage
in every urban metropolis with four
films premiere at Cannes this year and a
start earning little big lives which he
also co-produced this is a working mom
yeah wasn't it amazing this is a working
mum who juggles so well she could join
the Cirque du Soleil talented beautiful
brilliant porcelain skinned willowy wise
witty warm feminist fun and with a
figure so food but peachy it would cause
a heart attack in a sloth the woman's so
perfect she looks under dressed without
a plinth she should just carry one round
with her everywhere she goes
in fact this gifted thespian just makes
you want to go and get my own DNA steam
cleaned immediately glamorous film
actress of the year is the irresistible
glamazonian australian national treasure
and dear cherish pal of mine nicole
echidna Kidman Jesus KITT oh my gosh how
do I follow that thank you Cathy thank
you Joe and thank you glamour for having
me
tonight I so I am so happy I am here in
person to be able to give love back to
London because London has given me so
much so it is great to be standing here
with you strong I also want to say this
is I'm going to take this as a birthday
present I'm about to turn 50 in two
weeks and I would never have thought
this is going to be one of the best
years of my life so many things have
happened this year for me creatively and
I when I was about 40 I remember
thinking are at 50 I'll be retiring no
way so I want to tell all the women out
there it is not over at 40 it begins and
it even begins more at 50 and I also
want to thank the directors that I've
gotten to work with because as you know
as an actor you're only as good as the
directors that you work with so I was
chosen by these directors at this
particular time in my life to do these
really fantastic films but the one I
want to give a shout out to tonight
because this is a room full of women and
it's celebrating women is Sophia Coppola
because she won Best Director at the
Cannes Film Festival she is the first
woman in 56 years to win it so I shout
out to my girlfriend but I also want to
say I am changing my name to Nicole Kidd
woman I realize it's been wrong I cannot
be kid man I'm Kidd woman thank you
[Applause]